you mentioned bitcoin and maybe let's
start there in terms of uh there's a lot
of folks in the institutional asset
management world financial advisors uh
who they were very bearish they were
critics they said there's no way this is
going to work i think now we've gone
from kind of contrarian to consensus
being okay fine let's put one percent of
assets in uh there may be some
non-correlation over really long periods
of time or there may be some asymmetry
but let's not get too crazy let's not
try to get too confident here we'll put
half a percent one percent maybe two
percent
how do you think about the sizing of
these assets especially when you look at
you know five year sharp ratios and kind
of you know you get more sophisticated
analysis is this something where you
think people will stay kind of in that
low single digit percentage allocations
or do you already see financial advisors
talking about no actually we want you
know target allocations of 10 20 to the
space or what are you seeing and hearing
what do you think people should be doing
i think advisors are still in the low
single digit area uh that's where i am
and my advice to consumers in my book
the truth about crypto i talk about a
one percent asset allocation and i say
that because it's a safe easy
non-threatening way to get started
meaning if you put one percent of your
portfolio into this and it blows up on
you and it goes bad
yeah
so what you'll call it annoying not
devastating in other words if you put
one percent into bitcoin and bitcoin
blows up and becomes worthless
you're not going to destroy your
financial security you're not going to
find yourself in poverty in retirement
in other words it's okay to invest one
percent because if you do one percent
and things go as well as many hope
that one percent will materially improve
your financial future you might even be
able to retire sooner or with more money
so the upside reward dwarfs the downside
risk with a one percent allocation many
people are arguing that a more effective
approach is two or three or four percent
one study from yale says six percent of
assets is all you need but everybody's
talking low single digit my assumption
what my belief my prediction for you
pomp is that
over the next 10 years as people invest
one percent or two percent
they're going to discover that it grows
faster it doubles faster than any other
asset class it'll double faster than
stocks or bonds or real estate or gold
or oil and as a result the one percent
allocation will become 2
and then 4 and then 8 and then 16 and
they're not going to want to sell
because they're going to realize the
product that the price appreciation
potential still persists and they're not
going to want to sell so while they
might start out with a low single digit
allocation
inertia will take over and they will
discover they'll turn around one day and
they'll say oh i do have a 10 or 20
percent allocation simply because the
one or two percent i bought has grown so
much in value relative to the rest of my
assets and when you think about that is
there a rebalancing that you usually
advocate for or is it something where
it's just a buy and hold it forever and
if it grows to be you know 50 60 80 and
kind of all of the promises of the
technology end up being realized uh just
leave it and don't incur taxation or
whatever like how do you think about
if you are so
fortunate that you make the right
decisions and it grows in size how do
you think most people should uh should
deal with that
if you are going to manage the money the
way you're supposed to manage money
under modern portfolio theory and
effective money management you should
rebalance it helps you take money off
the table it captures your profits it
secures them and when the prices
occasionally dip as they're doing right
now it creates a buying opportunity so
yes you should rebalance having said
that
i will tell you that i have never
rebalanced my crypto allocations which
is one of the reasons i am very
overweighted in crypto right now because
my wife and i have been buying since 20
uh we got started in bitcoin in 2012
started buying in 2014 we've never
sold any of our positions because
although i of course believe in
rebalancing and i do it everywhere else
in my portfolio i continue to believe
that the upside is incredibly strong and
i'm not willing to pair back because i
believe it's the best asset class in my
portfolio and i don't see the point of
rebalancing i recognize i'm taking
bigger risks as i do it we are willing
to take those risks we can afford to
take the risk uh we don't have children
so there's nobody's inheritance that
we're destroying so you know we're just
having a good time with it but for most
folks i would say yeah rebalance be
prudent do the right thing and i'm going
to throw another thing out there that
you quickly mentioned in passing and
that was taxes
taxes are a very big significant issue
for
crypto owners like all investors because
you got to pay taxes on the profits this
is why i'm so excited about fidelity's
announcement that they're going to allow
the 401k plans that fidelity manages the
world's biggest 401k provider here in
the u.s 2.7 trillion in assets for 23
000 employers
over 10 million workers
they're now going to let all of those
workers buy bitcoin inside the 401k this
is great news because the 401k or ira is
the best place to be buying bitcoin
because you're doing it in a tax
deferred environment where you can trade
without having to incur taxes as you do